make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are picking back up again
with the boys yes we are covering the
boys yet again for all of you guys who
love it as always the uncensored version
will go on patreon and the censored
version will come out here on YouTube
what I'm also gonna start doing is I'm
gonna start uploading videos that
YouTube would normally do monetize
because of their policies I'm gonna
upload those videos onto patreon those
will strictly go up there and then we'll
kind of go forward with comments
explained as normal having said that the
boys are really really doing this one
this was a lot of exposition it's one of
these weird things like Garth Ennis
basically gives us like a whole mission
they're going on and then it's just a
bunch of crazy things that happen in
between but all this really picks up
with a couple of situations going on the
first one is of course you pick up with
a billy butcher talking with you know
the CIA was susan directly in some cafe
more or less some restaurant but then at
the same time released before that
really leading into like this mission
you had a chick named silver Kincaid and
she had the ability to control pressure
or gravity it's not explicitly defined
here it's just something going on with
that but she basically walked out to a
corner on a street asked where's uncle
Paul and then basically killed herself
you know it's kind of crazy because it
looks like she used pressure to kind of
cave herself in but regardless of the
situation she basically ended up dying
and so the question that cadet goes on
here is why like what led to this what
was going on behind the scenes what
caused her to do this remember the boys
basically functioned were any kind of
abnormal activity that deals with
superheroes is always really assigned to
them by virtue of the CIA it's the
nature of their team and it's the role
that they play and so what we end up
doing is learning about this group
called the g-men
now the realities of the g-man were
basically designed to kind of be like a
parody of the x-men it's really what
they are right they're a parody of the
x-men themselves largely because of the
fact that the group is basically led by
a guy named John Eagan Dalton who's
really like a stand-in for for Charles
Xavier albeit far more sinister than
than anything else but what you also
have is basically g-force gee whiz and G
style now these are kind of under the
g-men right so it's almost like you have
x-men then you have x-force x-factor
different things like that is really
kind of how this compares in terms of
the the groups and how they work with
one another but the big question is
being asked here is what's the deal with
John Goodell Ken right like how does
this guy function and what's going on
with his character the problem with this
is that there's not really a lot of
information coming out when it comes to
the G min right there is not really a
super clandestine group so much as a
group where like people just don't
really spill the beans right so the only
way for the boys to really learn
anything about their organization is to
sin
one of their guys in basically sendin
Hughie who's disguised as one of the
g-men the other thing about this which
is hilarious is the seven keep getting
crank calls and it's one of the funniest
things homeland or gets this call where
it's like are there any walls there and
it's like no look at like I think you've
got the wrong number
and it's like then how does the roof
stay off it's corny as hell but it's
hilarious like it's it's funny to see
that happen because he's absolutely
losing his mind from there that's when
you basically start getting into
gee-whiz you start getting into them
into the g-men now the idea behind this
is Huey joining in as part of their
group this guy has no clue what in the
world he was getting into here right the
guys got no earthly clue now while all
that's going on you've also got mother's
milk who's kind of investigating from
the other side he's really really
focusing more on on Silverson silver
Kincaid more so than anything else but
the hope is that by investigating her
that will basically lead into maybe some
trails some breadcrumbs or something
like that they can kind of get him some
information on the g-man and of course
he and Huey can basically compare notes
and see where where the whole
organization stands but the problem with
the g-man is at least with these up with
these guys these gee whiz guys it's
they're kind of all over the place right
like they're kind of bunkers and so far
as the group's just sort of like let
their whims and wants carry them to
carry them abroad on it's a it's a crazy
life of like debauchery is it is really
what it is but that's when you also end
up learning this group were the ones who
were prank calling home Lander and they
got the number from like the directory
right as it is really kind of where they
got this from you know make these crank
calls and and so on and so forth but the
big just behind this and really one of
the big things that comes out of this is
what you have going on here is that in
response to the death of silver Kincaid
you basically got this big memorial
going on with regards to all the various
g-men groups that exist out there now
the nature of the g-men and really kind
of feeding into the fact that it's like
a parody on the x-men and the expedited
universe there's a whole bunch of
different groups here right so you
basically got the G Brits you've got the
genome and you've got the G Coast G
style and gee whiz you have a whole
bunch of these these different
organizations these different functions
that are kind of out there with regards
to them you know going out and doing
their own thing something else that
really seems to come out of this is
about American is aware of who the g-men
are of everything that goes on the g-men
they're aware of GAD all kin and and so
on and so forth the issue with this is
that the death of silver can cave it'll
drive people to start asking questions
which is exactly what's going on now but
remember when it comes to bought
American their Charter first and
foremost is make as much money as you
can and don't let anybody
interrupts the flow of money I like the
spice must flow for those of you guys
who know the reference from dune but
still there's a lot that goes on here
with these with these different g-man
organizations so here we getting in
there and here we basically pretending
to be one of their members really passes
like the initial test and so of course
eventually he's brought before Johnny
adulkin and that's what the questions
asked like why do you want to join this
and is like what I've always want to be
a superhero which is really kind of like
a pretty cut-and-dry answer and this one
that's usually accepted right because
when it comes to the idea of the g-men
or even with the idea of a bought
American the only thing that's really
concerned about is are you bankable do
you have powers and are you a person
that can be marketed in such a way to
where you can generate large amounts of
revenue that's the number one overriding
factor when it comes to bad Americans
interactions with the entirety of the
superhero community if you're not
marketable they don't care about you if
you are marketable then they definitely
care about right and there's a whole
host of things that go into it in
addition to that there's small little
things that kind of pop up here and
there that basically tell you
something's not right right because if
you look at this on the surface it's
like okay it's just a bunch of crazy
guys who basically do all kinds of stuff
it seems part and parcel so like what
Huey and all they've have seen is part
of the superhero community right there's
the front public face the marketing face
of the superhero community then there's
everything else you know there's there's
there's all kinds of other stuff that
goes on behind the scenes and so looking
at this it's like okay especially just
people who are a little bonkers and
crazy you know but for the most part
Huey sees them as relatively good guys
right I mean they're not going out and
killing people but what is up happening
here is in the middle of this you end up
having Huey who basically goes to the
restroom only to be met by nubia who's
just kind of there and just saying kill
me you know over and over again and
scaring the absolute daylights out of he
now of course Nubia is basically a play
on the character of storm but when Huey
starts to freak out and lose his mind
everybody else comes running in and it's
like no dude that's the only thing she
ever says just chill relax it'll be cool
and of course there's a kind of hidden
thing here where it work at all kids
like well we've tried to stop her
nighttime and excursions we'll go ahead
and put her back in the old quarterback
we're supposed to where she's supposed
to be the idea is that she's almost kind
of like a dirty little secret when it
comes to the demon it's almost kind like
no one's supposed to know what's going
on with his care and am I supposed to
know what's what's going on with it the
other half of this is that we're mothers
milk is kind of tracing down this notion
of silver Kincaid right this idea that
she was an orphan and she was ultimately
rescued or at least taken from some kind
of an orphan home and basically brought
to to become part of the team and one of
the things he learns is that there's no
history of her living in that location
right there's no history of her being
there instead it's just kind of like the
this girl seemingly does kind of
appeared in the g-man out of nowhere and
nobody really has any definitive answers
as to how she got there or where she's
from the other half of this and the
reason why that the g-men are in reality
kind of becoming a liability to Vaught
American is it really comes by way of
some statements that are offered you
know from critter about while they're
having their morning brunch and one of
the things that critter says here is
that the g-man concept the ideology has
basically expanded to around like seven
or eight teens and you have like six or
seven people per team and so the the
problem with this is that it creates a
scenario where the more people they're
out there the more people can say
something and the reason why is is it
simple numbers right it's much much
easier to control what can or cannot be
said it's much easier to control the
narrative when you're talking about like
six people right because he ORS is kinda
like hey looked like all off all of you
guys or something like that but you
can't really manage you know something
if we're talking about at max you know
you talk about seven seven people and
there's 18 you so about 56 people one of
those folks is bound to say something so
there's a lot of security issues they go
on there with regards to this
organization so again that's one of the
interesting things about the g-men is
what kind of given this depiction where
you have this loose affiliation not even
really a loose affiliation but this
affiliation of teams that are out there
all under the banner of g-men with no
real oversight outside of like one guy
basically you know and it's kind of like
okay so like how do you control a group
like this you know how do you keep this
group under wraps how do you keep the
contain and controlled and will actually
find out that their allegiance to tick
adulkin is really like second to none
but there's a pretty nefarious reason as
to why that is but one of the things
that I also want to do is I want to
focus here on on the whole scenario with
Huey and and and his girl and the reason
why is because with Anna and all the
things that go on what he's been doing
is basically lying about his existence
the entire time he's been lying about
the role that he plays where he's
basically they say well you know I'm
basically a guy who investigates
insurance fraud you know something along
those lines the problem with this is
that these lies and deceit that Huey is
is coming out with at some point along
the line they're gonna have to come out
like either he's gonna slip or
somebody's gonna dump some information
or something along those lines and when
it hits the fan what's gonna happen like
how's this gonna play out how she's
gonna respond is you gonna lose your
mind and kill him but it's one of these
crazy things were it's like Huey is
becoming more and more comfortable being
one of the boys then when he first
started out the boys exist by way of
deceit they exist by way of Lies
manipulation Huey was a little put off
by that he's like I don't really know
that's a life for
I don't really know if I can be the kind
of person they can engage in those kinds
of actions but notice it's becoming much
much much easier for him as time goes on
it's becoming a lot easier for him to
manipulate these things as time goes on
and so it's kind of a crazy scenario
that you see unfold here in terms of the
character progression of Huey albeit in
somewhat of a negative way now following
this and this is one of the reasons why
mother milk is so cool is because what
he's been doing is tracking down every
conceivable lead he can find in terms of
what's been going on with silver Kidd
silver Kincaid and what he does is he
basically locates a guy named mr.
Wilhelm who basically had this younger
brother named Paul who ended up
travelling out and going all the way to
like a motel in Arizona and essentially
offing himself and the question is why
and this is one of the reasons why
mother milk is so cool right because
mother milk it's very easy to look at
him it's kind of being like that the
strong guy of the boys right kind of
like the muscle behind the group and it
just kind of chalk him up and just say
okay Scott go for it but the guy's one
heck of an investigator and what he
basically learned here at least you know
talking to mr. Wilhelm what he learns is
that at some point along the line
Paul had a niece and the result of this
was that this this little girl a her
name was grace he took her out for ice
cream and of course you know once they
got ice cream together it was it was an
amazing time and because of his
experience with her Paul was looking
forward to the idea of having a daughter
himself of course realizing he forgot
his change he went back into the ice
cream store and when he came out grace
was gone and nobody had seen anything
right that was the only response anybody
ever really gave the the Sheriff's
Office's we didn't see anything we don't
know what went on we have no idea what
happened here this girl basically just
damaged try she just disappeared up in
smoke and that was the biggest problem
is that try as they might now assuming
that the sheriff's office gave it their
all there was nothing they could do to
locate this girl nobody knew where she
went to nobody knew anything about her
nobody saw who took her or anything
along those lines there were no there
was no description of a vehicle nothing
and so as a result of that kind of
driven by guilt driven by all of this
Paul ended up driving out into a motel
in Arizona and basically just offing
himself right it was the only way he
seemed to be able to cope with what was
going on here but that's when things
begin to click for Mother's Milk because
when he hears that when he's like well
this guy Paul was her uncle that's when
it harkens back to what she said on the
street corner where's uncle Paul that's
that's the quote legis is one of these
really really cool moments here because
it's like it all kind of clicks into
place
and so what mother's milk ends up doing
is kind of piecing together this
Meredith piecing together this story
that's somewhere along the line that
uncle Paul had taken race tune and ice
cream he went back inside and and grace
was kidnap presumably by John
I kind of see that I don't know who else
would be and he's literally the guy
who's like the villain of the of the
comics so far or at least here in this
one particular story and she basically
vanished you know but because of the
fact that uncle Paul was her uncle
presumably she went through all these
different experiences who really knows
what happened although we'll find out
later on at the end of the story and
that's who she was looking for where's
uncle Paul like I need a uncle Paul is
kind of a crazy thing but there's
actually a lot more going on to her
character insofar as why she was the way
she was but there's this really really
cool conversation that takes place
between Hughie and building butcher
right because Hughie kind of finds these
small little moments to basically break
away and essentially report back of
course all these bits of information are
kind of dumped out there and of course
he's plan of the various monitoring
devices and and you know these bugs and
so on and so forth but what he basically
says is like look they're not inherently
bad guys like these these are not bad
guys or not they're not villains right
they're not like heroes that don't care
about people or anything like that like
there's kind of guys who were there and
they care about each other but I don't
think that we should really be going in
the direction of like let's take these
guys out right because we know that
Billy butcher doesn't really much care
about about any of this any of the
superheroes it's about just like taking
these guys out because they're all
basically various threats if they can't
be used to achieve a goal they can be
removed from the landscape that's kind
of Billy what's your stance on things
but the idea behind what he was telling
him is look man like they're not
inherently bad people so like if we're
gonna make a move on John Gaddafi and
we're gonna take this guy out at the
very least what we can do is remove
these guys in the equation and try to
help them become like better people
right it's a pretty cool thing and it's
good to see that Huey hasn't fallen so
far down this path that he sees all
superheroes as being like irredeemable
in the same fashion as Billy butcher you
know so again like well fought American
is Mickey moves and essentially saying
these g---men have become too extreme
they become too much of a liability Huey
is basically taken by some of the guys
from the g-men kind of brought out to
you not really the middle of nowhere so
much of some place sort of off the
beaten path from where the reunions
going are I guess the memorials going on
they dragged him out of the car and they
basically say we know what's going on
about you right like we've been told
that you're not looking to join the
g-men that you're a spy so was one of
the like is one of these instances right
off the bat where he doesn't really get
busted like immediately but he gets
busted pretty quickly and it's kind of a
funny thing here because what this
really shows and it's one of the big
moments that goes on when it comes to
the to the nature of the boys the boys
comic as well as like even the
superheroes themselves is that for all
the pomp and circumstance of Billy
butcher you know kind of point of the
finger superheroes and say they're not
really trained to be these kind of guys
they don't really know what they're
doing the same kind
goes to the boys they're capable and
having some influence in the CIA things
like that does benefit them but they're
by no means perfect and the fact that he
we got busted in this way really kind of
shows hey these guys aren't necessarily
perfect now of course we could all get
had a hand in figuring all this stuff
out but we're Huey is about to basically
bite the bullet right these guys are
gonna take Huey out they're gonna kill
him suddenly he's rescued by the female
as well as French eat and then the rest
of the boys basically join in and what
they end up doing is saving you'll see
any one of these one of these uh members
of the g-man not really for the purpose
of like making his life better but to
basically say spill the beans tell us
what's going on here and what we end up
learning is that we'd all Kane had been
going out and kidnapping young kids and
so what he would do is is once these
kids were kids were kidnapped they would
constantly inject them like once a week
with with compound V the serum it gives
people superpowers and one of two things
would happen either they would develop
powers or they would die and that was
just the way it was and so as a result
of that for those individuals who lived
who ended up kind of going on and
basically developing abilities they
would in turn be incorporated into the
g-men and then basically go forward
doing the bidding of Django Dalton the
reason why the American allowed this to
go on for so long is because the g-men
produced a ton of money right I mean
they're basically views like castoffs as
people who's you know by virtue of their
power manifesting had like a kind of a
different appearance or something like
that but they reviewed it's like the
underdog and people love an underdog and
so they basically generated a ton of
money for fraud American which is why
bought American sort of let it go on and
so they were basically raised with this
ideology of never tell anybody what
happens to you and you'll be able to
live continue living this amazing life
and when you're a little kid and you're
as easily manipulable as the the kids
that are shown in here and you're
basically given every opportunity to do
whatever it is that you want it's pretty
screwed up like it's pretty dark and
it's pretty twisted and so as a result
of that what you end up basically
getting is this notion of these kids
going forward and basically swearing
absolute allegiance to John get all
convinced Lee saying like we're never
gonna wrap this guy out we're never
gonna turn on this guy you know once you
end up having like Billy butcher and all
of his forces or I guess really him in
just the boys who we're not going to
confront all these various superheroes
none of it makes a difference because
seemingly out of nowhere you have all
these soldiers all these henchmen for
von American who come running in here
with Stinger missiles with helicopters
flamethrowers and just torch everything
they torch and eliminate everyone like
every single member of these g-men is is
literally just like a great big huge
sanitation project they Sam
ties everything they eliminate all of
them like all of them are gone and the
reason why is because now there's no
more liability there's no more having to
worry about other people talking and
what it really does is it is it points
to this idea that nothing is beyond
bought American they'll do whatever they
need to in order to make sure that their
assets their profits are kept in line
that nobody gets in the way
then nobody stops the flow of money and
they're willing to cut off some money
they're willing to cut off the financial
flow from the g-men so long as nobody
gets in the way right and here's kind of
the crazy thing about it because what
American approaches this from a
marketing standpoint what they could
really do here is they could spin the
narrative to say any number of things
some extreme group out there whatever
the case is you know they went through
and took out all the g-men and so that
way not American kind of paints them is
like martyrs more or less and so that
way it'll increase the sales of their
comic books and Vaughn American will
continue making money it's pretty
nefarious and it's pretty extreme but
it's the way in which their organization
functions so that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here too comments explained make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
purse
you